[BLANK_AUDIO]
As I mentioned earlier, I can't really teach you software design. You have to
actively learn it. To encourage this, part of your grade for the course will be
a measure of your participation in it. This is necessarily a subjective element,
but I can let you know of some of the considerations that go into it.
First is your teammates' evaluations of you on the projects and assignments.
Also your engagement in the quizzes that are part of the lessons. Third is your
non-gratuitous participation on the class form. I consider this course, itself,
as a design project. Although it has been offered many times before, it has
necessarily been adapted to deal with the constraints of web-based delivery and
a large number of students. Therefore, I expect some elements will work
better than others. I specifically would like to solicit your contributions,
such as the following. First, any bugs in the material. These can be as
trivial as typos, or as vague as questions about unclear lesson content.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
If you have any suggestions for additional content, as long as the suggestions
fit within the general intent of the course. Also, specific examples, either
generated by you or ones that you have seen that were particularly edifying.
Alternative assignments or assignment questions. Even suggestions for
style elements that might be added to the course. In general, the first
contributor on a particular item will get primary credit for that contribution.